reims devant la cour d'assises dès
mineurs de la marne toujours à huit clos
les jurés chargés de juger patrick dils
pour le meurtre de deux enfants mais
être commis en 1986 ont entendu
aujourd'hui le témoignage de francis
heaulme sauteurs en série présents sur
les lieux du crime au moment des faits
ils ont aussi écouté un adjudant de
gendarmerie qui a longuement enquêté sur
francis oms est essentiel aux yeux de la
défense de patrick 10 pour démontrer
l'innocence de celui-ci
compte rendu d'audience valérie ermite
et rémy poissonnier la prison de metz
il est 6h30 du matin dans ce faux bond
cellulaire francis heaulme est en route
pour aller témoigner
quelques minutes plus tôt patrick dils
arrive lui aussi au palais de justice de
reims
étrange l'image de l'arrivée de deux
suspects d'un même crime
sous le regard de la grand mère d'une
des deux victimes on veut savoir qui a
fait ça
qui que ce soit qui que ce soit qui ce
soit qui que ce soit deux heures
d'interrogatoire des contradictions dans
son emploi du temps le jour du double
meurtre mais pour le reste
francis heaulme n'a pas bougé il a
répondu qu'il n'a jamais tué les enfants
qui n'a jamais tué qui n'a jamais touché
des enfants qui ne les a jamais vus et
ceci de manière claire nette et
indiscutable à la question
auriez-vous tué ses deux enfants et vous
pu tuer ses deux enfants la réponse est
oui mais je ne vais pas faire avant au
l'ex gendarme ac bras les venues
témoigner en 1992 lorsqu'il arrête le
tueur en série francis heaulme lui dit
spontanément avoir vu dans l'est de la
france
deux enfants morts le long d'une voie
ferrée en 1997 lorsque l'enquêteur on
entend parler de l'interdît il fait
immédiatement le lien est écrit
officiellement à la justice c'est la
première approche qui la lie jusqu'à
présent pour expliquer les morts pour
lesquels il a été confondu
c'est toujours de petites saynètes comme
ça qu'ils expliquent les détours témoin
où il arrive toujours sur une scène de
crime pour vous francis heaulme est
forcément impliqué d'une manière ou
d'une autre ils ont que jusqu'à présent
chaque fois qu'il a dit quelque chose à
chaque fois ils étaient présents sont
ces deux crimes et à chaque fois il a
été l'auteur des faits à la barre des
témoins francis heaulme s'adresse aux
familles des victimes
je vous donne ma parole d'homme que je
n'ai pas tué vos deux enfants puis de
manière assez énigmatique parle de
patrick dils
je ne le crois pas coupable dit il et je
lui souhaite bonne chance